catherine verdier qui résident sur place
et qui exercent d'ailleurs au luxembourg
en tant que psychologue bonsoir
catherine verdier merci d'être avec nous
en direct alors le port du masque
évidemment c'est quelque chose qui nous
intrigue en france puisque vous savez on
a une petite polémique sur le sujet pas
franchement utile au départ pour les
membres du gouvernement qui devient de
plus en plus utile même obligatoire
bientôt dans les transports comment ça
se passe chez vous au luxembourg ça veut
dire que chacun chaque habitant reçoit
un masque oui tout à fait tout à fait
depuis le début on a eu au départ du
confinement il ya eu quelques
difficultés à obtenir des masques mais
au fur et à mesure ça c'est ça c'est
bien ça s'est bien améliorée et puis
effectivement hier pour la première
journée du déconfinement chaque foyer a
reçu un paquet avec cinq masques par
personne donc cinq masques chaque chaque
personne du foyer a reçu cinq masques
pour démarrer et les entreprises et les
sociétés qui ont démarré effectivement
aussi lundi les entreprises du btp ont
effectivement reçu des masques pour les
employés puisque c'est la condition
obligatoire pour un déconfinement alors
justement vous parlez de déconfinement
condition obligatoire porter un masque
on imagine qu'il ya d'autres mesures à
respecter dans une distanciation sociale
quelles sont les autres mesures à
appliquer pour les enfants et tout à
fait tout les toutes les mesures
barrières qui existent et qu'ils doivent
continuer d'exister obligatoirement
toute la distanciation social au niveau
des au niveau des magasins des magasins
dénuement d'alimentation une distance à
respecter qui est de mettre et puis et
puis les les sorties qui sont pas qu'ils
sont pas libres non plus on est moins
confiné et on a les auteurs on n'a pas
besoin d'autorisation pour sortir mais
disons qu'on reste dans le même cadre
dans le même cadre qu'auparavant quoi
alors il ya moins d'habitants en france
un évidement toutes proportions gardées
m et enfin le bilan est tout même traîné
et plus de 70 décès à quoi attribuer ce
bilan assez léger comment était géré
cette épidémie au luxembourg je crois
que je crois qu'elle a été très très
bien gérée qui lie à les hôpitaux avait
tout ce qu'il fallait pour pour gérer
cette crise il ya eu 34 milles je crois
tu est d'opérer sur six cent mille
habitants donc c'est beaucoup voilà les
il y avait 6000 réservistes également
aussi pour le pour aider aux hôpitaux je
me suis présenté mais je ne savais pas
besoin de moi
voilà mes donc il y avait il y avait du
matériel il ya eu un hôpital
supplémentaires qui a été construit
juste prend fin moi je les vis de mes
fenêtres voilà et puis tout le monde
était mobilisé et tout le monde était
sur le pont et je crois franchement que
les toutes les mesures barrières ont été
soigneusement respectée alors vous
parlez d'un hôpital qui a été construit
évidemment ça nous intrigue en si peu de
temps
oui oui tout à fait tout à fait une
annexe à l'hôpital principal qui a été
construite en quelques jours les a vus
on les a vus construire ça en quelques
jours en très peu de temps à la chinoise
en fait
autre information nous en france
importante jean michel blanquer a donné
son calendrier détaillé pour les
écoliers ça va se passer en trois fois
chez nous expliquez nous un petit peu
comment ça s'est passé au luxembourg
parce que ici évidemment ça crée le
débat beaucoup de professeurs non non
pas franchement envie de retourner
travailler ils dénoncent des conditions
sanitaires qui ne sont pas respectées
comment ça s'est passé chez vous ça va
se passer c'est à dire que le
gouvernement autorise certaines
professions à recommencer à travailler
donc le btp hier les fleuristes les
magasins de bricolage
il ya un laps de temps qui va s'écouler
sans que quoi que ce soit se passe et
puis le 4 mai démarre effectivement pour
les écoles les en fait on a le temps
beau on fait l'inversé de la france
c'est à dire qu'on met les en mai à
l'école en dernier les petits les plus
jeunes donc en premier ce sont ceux qui
passent le bac etc
en deuxième le 11 mai les collégiens et
les lycéens
et puis le 23 mai sont prévues les
petits primaires et maternelles et
crèches alors ya eu évidemment un
confinement chez vous aussi vous êtes un
psychologue
on le rappelle quelles sont les
conséquences vous avez peut-être un tout
petit peu plus de recul que nous pour en
parler
les conséquences psychologiques du
confinement les conséquences elles sont
nombreuses on est on est on est tous en
situation de stress post traumatique
même si les conditions sont privilégiés
même s'il ya pas beaucoup de cas au
regard du regarde la population ça reste
un confinement avec toutes les
inquiétudes qui vont derrière avec les
incertitudes pour le pour l'avenir
également
donc voilà maintenant depuis là depuis
hier en fait
hier c'était la fin des vacances
scolaires des vacances de pâques ou
luxembourg est depuis hier c'est très
curieux mais c'est très difficile pour
les enfants de reprendre ce rythme ainsi
que pour les parents il est maman et
j'ai plusieurs demandes de consultation
alors j'en avais pas beaucoup avant mais
pour pour les aider parce que la reprise
la reprise des cours à l'école à la
maison car dont la reprise du travail du
télétravail etc
c'est c'est beaucoup c'est vraiment
beaucoup je crois que les gens n'ont
vraiment vraiment marre si je puis me
permettre
merci beaucoup catherine verdier
psychologue et thérapeute fondatrice
notamment de psy famille
merci pour votre témoignage de cette
situation au luxembourg